when i was young
everyone wanted to be engine drivers on
the train
and probably this is the nearest i'll
ever get to it and i've had to wait 74
years to get to this point
so i'm really excited and i do like this
picture here
it's got a slightly strange molecule
here
perhaps you the viewers can guess what
it is i'm not sure what it is and it's
got an atom too and a flask where the
reaction seems to be going slightly
wrong so it's really nice
and my name is spelt correctly which is
quite a triumph when i got an honor from
the queen they spelt my name correctly
but they misspelt nottingham on the
certificate so
here you've got it correct
p for peter over orange l for london i
for india a for apple
k for king over orange for frederick for
frederick
i think it's great
and it's my birthday
ever since the tram reached beeston
i've been using it at least till the
start of the pandemic and i think it's a
fantastic
method of transport it's really good for
our city so i'm really pleased to be
honored by it and it's very gratifying
that my fellow citizens should
appreciate the work that we're doing at
the university
i particularly like the button for
warming the driver's feet it's one of
the best presents that i've had on a
birthday for a long time
i'm getting so old people don't give me
presents much anymore and so this was a
really good present and one which will
last
i will be reminded of it every time i
get on the tram or see the tram going
past
through the beast and where i live
so i think
it couldn't have happened on a better
day
and i've also been given
a plaque
which will probably go in my office
which has the triumph with my name on it
so
i feel really quite honored
and my colleagues have said to me
it's better than getting a knighthood
better than the nobel prize
and i think i agree with them
it's really fun
and i don't know any other chemists who
have a tram named after them
look
there's one at the back as well
and a good piece of chemistry you can
press a button to put sands silicon
dioxide onto the track
to give extra traction
so
another element to add to the elements
of a tram